le sytral section qui est issu de
effectivement de ton de ton passé
d'entrepreneur avant de passer là la
parole à christian saint-etienne qui à
notre délégué général à l'économie au
niveau du république
j'aurais quand même dire qu'on est quand
même le seul pays au monde où on n'est
pas le droit ou à peine le droit de
travailler plus de 35 heures est pas le
droit de travailler moins de 24 y'a pas
d'autres pays au monde où on est cette
stupidité dans le système législatif
alors hier au cours d'un d'une
proposition de loi que nous allions
déposer ans avec les républicains nous
avons à demander la suppression de ces
24 heures et on nous a dit non parce que
c'est un système qui est très protecteur
ça et ça évite effectivement moi je
partage l'avis de daniel verdier molinié
tout à l'heure qui nous a dit que
effectivement il vaut mieux avoir des
gens qui un pied dans l'emploi
et puis à un filet social comme elle
nous l'a dit plutôt que d'avoir le
système dans lequel nous ayons alors je
passe la parole à christian
saint-etienne en lui demandant de
conclure cette table ronde avant de
passer la parole à luc ferry qui nous a
rejoint pour une vision beaucoup plus
haute des choses est question je te
laisse la parole
bon je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de choses
qui ont déjà été dites mais il faut
fixer un certain nombre de principes
n'effaçant un choix quasiment
constitutionnel et existentielle du
poids relatif de la loi et de l'accord
d'entreprise
je pense que effectivement eu ni faute
il faut privilégier l'accord
d'entreprise sur l'accord de branche et
d'une certaine façon permettre la
dérogation par rapport à la loi mais je
crois que comme ça a été dit par un
certain nombre d'intervenants
il faut que l'état assume également ses
responsabilités je circule beaucoup à
travers la france et beaucoup de chefs
d'entreprise alors je sais que ça va
vous surprendre mais beaucoup de chefs
d'entreprise nous disent mais c'est
quand même très bien de vouloir nous
donner des responsabilités conventionnel
nous sommes prêts à les assumer
mais ça doit être dans un cadre national
rodez finit donc je vais évoquer donc
comme seul instant quelques éléments de
mon point de vue de la redéfinition
qu'il faudrait faire on a évoqué
notamment avec franck morel l'autre
problème absolument clé dans notre pays
c'est ce que j'appellerais le problème
de l' embauche débauche
c'est à dire qu'on embauche pas quand on
peut pas débaucher c'est ce que tous les
pays du monde pratique si on peut pas
débaucher on n'embauche pas et donc
effectivement on a souvent discuté de ça
avec franck
je pense qu'il faut permettre d'offrir
un menu de contrats possibles entre les
salariés et les entrepreneurs j'y
reviendrai dans une seconde alors il y a
également la question des seuils
il ya le seuil de déclenchement de 50
pour créer un comité d'entreprise
je pense que comme nous le proposons
dans la dans les documents qui sont qui
circulent il faut évidemment fondre le
chc t il faut et avec le comité
d'entreprise
mais je pense qu'il faut le faire après
100 salariés et je pense que jusqu'à 100
salariés les délégués du personnel en
direct avec le chef d'entreprise
suffisent pour organiser l'entreprise de
ce point de vue là le droit social
français a été créé à la libération à un
moment au niveau d'éducation de la
population n'avait rien à voir avec ce
qu'il est aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui tous les salariés dans
l'entreprise un portable
tout le monde a un minimum
d'informations sur le fonctionnement du
monde niveau de qualification de la
population au travail a été a fortement
augmenté
donc je pense que dans ce contexte là il
faut faire confiance à l'accord entre
salariés et chefs d'entreprise dans la
définition d'un bien commun tout le
monde d'aujourd'hui comprend que c'est
par le développement de l'activité de
l'entreprise qui garantit les salaires
il n'y a aucune autre possibilité de
garantir les salaires quand faisons de
l'activité
alors justement sur ce point là je peux
pas le développer maintenant mais il ya
trois seuils clés de développement des
entreprises on avait beaucoup travaillé
sur ces sujets au conseil d'analysé
économique
il ya un seuil de 30 un seuil de 70 et
un seuil de 200 ce qui sont à chaque
fois des seuils de réorganisation
managériale et organisationnel
m le passage du comité d'entreprise à 50
ce n'est pas possible il ya un chef
d'entreprise tout ce matin je crois que
c'est
monsieur asselin qui a dit mais à partir
de 50 le chef d'entreprise est pris à
moitié de son temps par un travail de
drh or à partir de sang une entreprise a
forcément des rages qui peut prendre ces
éléments en charge et donc il est
absolument clé de faire en sorte que le
déclenchement de la création du comité
d'entreprise se fasse à 100 c'est à dire
au delà du niveau de 70 et le niveau à
partir duquel on doit pour favoriser le
développement d'une entreprise mettre en
place un comité de direction à
l'intérieur de l'entreprise donc ce sont
des choix pas seulement législatif il
faut intégrer les dimensions
managériales et organisationnelles dans
ses réflexions alors sur la durée de
travail
je pense qu'à un moment donné là aussi
laisser les chefs d'entreprise seul bien
sûr il faut redonner le pouvoir à la
négociation au sein de l'entreprise mais
dans un cadre national - à titre
personnel je pense qu'une durée annuelle
de travail 2007 150 eur + 250 heures de
2 supplémentaires payées à 10% de plus
et défiscalisées sauf pour les régimes
de retraite serait le moyen de permettre
ensuite aux accords d'entreprise de
rentrer dans davantage de détails mais
il faut une norme nationale c'est à dire
que là l'idée qu'on va redonner aux
chefs d'entreprises avec leurs salariés
en direct et je suis tout à fait
favorable au développement du référendum
de droit c'est à dire que le référendum
avec une majorité de voix auraient le
primat sur toute autre décision de
branche
je pense que c'est un élément clé un
autre point que je vais pas pouvoir
développer nous avons 700 branche en
france 70 suffirait aux normes
internationales je suis d'accord avec ce
que vous disais à l'instant avec des
pouvoirs avec un rôle réinventer de
service et donc en laissant aux accords
d'entreprise la décision la possibilité
d'intervenir et de prendre les décisions
alors je vais pas développer au delà
puisque on a des contraintes de temps
majeur mais je crois que l'idée centrale
c'est qu' il ne faut pas tomber dans la
facilité
parce que nous avons collectivement
échoué sur cette question 6 millions de
chômeurs c'est quand même le signe d'un
échec collectif absolument majeur depuis
30 ans gauche et droite confondues
c'est un échec fondamentale du majeur
est donc face à cet échec on ne peut pas
dire comme nous avons collectivement
échoué état syndicats on va filer le
bébé aux chefs d'entreprise non c'est
pas possible je pense que l'état doit
assumer toutes ses responsabilités en
imposant des règles claires et à partir
de ces règles claires à ce moment là les
entreprises pourront négocier des
accords d'entreprise mais sur une base
nationale clair merci